ac l'interruttore qualcuno [ __ ]
[ __ ] ei vestiti ragazzi
impedimenti questo video sono justin
bieber and day we are 3 insomma ci siamo
ragazzi in europa figo aspetta a parte
gli scherzi ma che figo c'è una grafica
della madonna che ora record siamo su su
brindisini è bello vi piace se vuoi su
grid berg lo gioco magari in inglese
sono carini giochi così che partono
soprattutto con questa bella schermata
grid del tesoro del great bear del gioco
di barbe the following his android che è
anche il mio pene è una lunga storia
cazzo di pisa buongiorno per caso io
sono justin bieber vorrai mica farmi del
male vero zio qualcosa si usa per
mettere i chiodi ascolta fratello
andranno mai consigliato degli occhiali
non sa anche un buon parrucchiere non è
male a joseph the babe si chiama lascio
ciao joseph come stagione bella la cia
era un ascia non era un martello ragazzi
scusate mi sono confuso dove vai vai ad
affidare josep zio arrivo ed e
tranquillo comunque salutamelo che mi
sta simpatico john hughes mouth to move
camera shirt col mouse di questo mio
mouse non è più è proprio un topo ma va
bene devo guardarmi in giro zio anche
noi c'è anche un altro suite gianfrate
né mi sto guardando in giro ragazzi ce
l'ha è uguale ad outlast pazzesco delle
belle mani sexy perfetta e non posso
alzare ma posso alzarmi
ma com è allora che cazzo di trappola e
questa mi aveva fatto sedere su una
sedia dove dalla quale posso alzarmi
allora scusami
dove sta il problema ma vedo che
ospitale come padrone di casa c'è una
leva lega non so che cazzo serva ma la
tiriamo perché le leve hanno sempre un
utilità ragazzi che cazzo fatto al vero
sono stato io
va beh non scherzava non so se c'è una
luce gesù sei tu gesù non è gesù non è
mai gesù ragazze ora bello zio 6 sonno e
devi riposarti c'è una sedia li usiamo
questa scia anche per tagliare un po i
rami che cazzo dice porca merda solo
cascato
ma vaffan no non ci credo mai lui sono
caduto sono cascate in un burrone tempo
10 secondi chiaro libero fantastico due
sono smorto ovviamente ciao ciao
c'è il mio al mouse il mouse ragazzi voi
non avete visto niente vero che non
avete visto io non ho visto niente giuro
che è bello furto è andato di cuore bene
chiudiamo la porta prima che ci venga
addosso quello schifo di merda non si
chiude la porta [ __ ] vacca se mi
salta un ragno addosso ma non e gli
schiaffi è un ragno grasso come il mio
culo ma [ __ ] vi sembra normale
ragazzi ma la pulisce casa padrone di
merda quella cha che c'hai che vuoi
usare per me la puoi usare per un
miliardo di altre cose quali tagliare i
rami ammazzare i ragni ce ne sono un
sacco di cose che puoi fare con quella
assai zio
vediamo di scegliere le giuste
ecco che cazzo vado
madonna che brutta cosa ma che brutta
cosa
che brutta cosa che cos'è giorno sono
lorenzo mi chiamano ci sono altri topi i
topi van bene ragazzi topi finché ci
sono intoppi però devo uccidere queste
cose cazzo mi sono il telefono del v6 ti
sembra al momento di chiamarmi mentre mi
porca [ __ ] ci sono dei vani grossi
ragazzi ci assiste anche ubriachi come
se non bastasse fantasy perché bisogna
blocca ovvio possiamo chiudere le porte
che attraversiamo no hai rotto il cazzo
aiutami tu justin non rompetemi kolja
vedo che qua ci hanno fatto un party
perfetto parti con del vino rosso
ragazzi ac l'interruttore qua ma
[ __ ] [ __ ] [ __ ] che
cazzo mio dio no o mio dio no ragazzi
madonna che schifo che schifo di merda a
dio mio dio regalare né accendiamo la
luce [ __ ] justin non serve un
cazzo devi buttarli via i ragni to
cos'era abbiamo bisogno di trovare una
chiave certo me l'ha trovato zio la
chiave che tra tutte le cose che
potranno mettere i ragni perché era in i
legami è una roba normale cos'è questo è
un frigo c'è la nutella ragazzi almeno
quella dai avete finita tutta un cestino
pezzi [ __ ] vaffan cuore c'è un tuono un
tuono sì sì sì ho capito to the basta vi
prego no vabbè rega ma vi fa che cazzo
di problemi anni croato ma perché
andavano erano così belli i topi perché
ma [ __ ] tua madre ciao ciao
spero che il ragno si mangi lui
laggiù laggiù laggiù perfetto vai via
via via via via via chiudi st porta di
merda non si chiude ragazzi non si
chiude la porta perfetto dove cazzo
faccio io rimango qua e qua e qua e qua
e qua e qua devi togliere in un passo
regalo un passo ciao ciao piacere fa vj
bene a mosse chiuso la porta siete
stronzi puoi venire almeno nella mia
direzione che cosa meno trova indietro e
vado avanti
ecco bravo grazie ma porca [ __ ]
si ok no no e no
[ __ ] ma [ __ ] tutta la rosa
merda che c'era gli horrors con questo
attraverso la somma morto fantastico
respaù rai spari non c'è più c'è il culo
casa per casa natale perfetto va bene
così va bene così sentiti non è che ce
ne sono altri di piu cosi
vi prego averci avevo al maestro avevi
qua l'importante non è tanto aver
trovato questa stanza che cosa che la
chiave ce l'ho l'ho presa io ho trovato
la chiave che dovrei farmi tutto il
[ __ ] corridoio tardo è anche tu
tranquilli calmi devo arrivare a quel mi
serve quella porta litio mi serve cola
portali quindi se per caso ti togli dal
cazzo mi fai un piacere è perfetto non è
passato nel passato sì sì sì sì ma che
ganso non a lorenzo come sempre io no
vabbè con bella la casa comune possa
affittarla io ma gag el mona che sbatte
le porte lì il bagno lo usate nel modo
giusto rega c'è il sangue porta qua e
numeri dire lo sapevo lo sapevo
vi si vede attraverso lo specchio ma
serve
visto che sei nella vasca da bagno
dentro spalmati pagine piene di sangue a
posto e affogato sono sono morto così a
poi fai non c'è più a caso c'è il bello
ragazzi che le morti in questo gioco
sono fatte apposta
bisogna proprio morire per andare avanti
se no non va bene nel gioco più strano
che abbia mai fatto nella mia vita però
che ti dà una mano se vuoi
no non voleva una mano lega non voleva
una mano perfetto scherzando però se
vorrai in futuro una mano ci stanno
osservando ciò significa servano cessi
si è tolta la musica justin cazzo fai
anche tu che vuole quel tizio che cazzo
fai porca [ __ ] e veloce molto veloce
flash da o salgono le scale stato bello
eh va beh è la luce la pagate alla
bolletta giorno prima sono arrivato di
qua ci sono le fogne
cazzo ma allora siete bastardi porte non
stavo scherzando torno indietro grazie
l'accoglienza prima di tutto rispetto
per le persone che vanno a trovare gli
altri accoglienza accendete le luci che
sul serio non funziona più
ha funzionato una volta è stato
incredibile festa musica che sostendo
che
esageratamente e quindi tre cazzo
sfornando lega spiegate non c'era un
corridoio lungo preferito tagliare per
di guardo solo camminare e per la giunta
come un ebete pure basta
tutti che fai così devo salire ancora di
più già fatta c'è gran cosa ragazzi
[ __ ] di ragni i ragazzi io e
justin bieber ce l'abbiamo fatta per
essere una demo non era niente male
cazzo che grafica anche la grafica dei
giochi non è tutto però porca [ __ ]
per una volta che c'è un horror con una
roba del genere tanto di cappello
quindi ragazzi che un covi episodio è
stato veramente figo ma proprio
divertente soprattutto anzi penso che lo
rifarò domattina i ragazzi se il video è
piaciuto come se il grosso aumento mi
piace però gli piace che mettete justin
bieber riprenderà un po di carne perché
non ne ha se avessi di essere felici
vita non fossimo vivo ma porca [ __ ]
bella ragazzi